[Music]  Katie Holmes and Jamie Foxx get cozy at  the beach it was great it was wonderful  the couple enjoyed an outing in Malibu  where they packed on the PDA the  notoriously private couple kissed and  hugged on the sand the adorable pair  also got playful Fox held the actress as  she attempted to do a cartwheel their  day of Fun in the Sun comes after  break-up rumours surrounded the pair in  late June however a source told et at  the time that the couple was very much  together quote it's not uncommon for  them to go long stretches without seeing  each other and they're still very very  private  adding you're not going to hear or see  every time they're together because they  don't flaunt their relationship in  public if I do fall in love with  somebody  you'll never know about  [Music]